please thank you thank you very much
we're here on this very beautiful spring
day in the Rose Garden to unveil our
plan to create a fair modern and lawful
system of immigration for the United
States and it's about time if adopted
our plan will transform America's
immigration system into the pride of our
nation and the envy of the modern world
our proposal builds upon our nation's
rich history of immigration while
strengthening the bonds of citizenship
that bind us together as a national
family throughout our history we have
proudly welcomed newcomers to our shores
out of many people from many places we
have forged one people and one nation
under God and we're very proud of it we
share the same home we share the same
destiny and we pledge allegiance to the
same great American flag
our policies have turbocharged our
economy now we must implement an
immigration system that will allow our
citizens to prosper for generations to
come
today we are presenting a clear contrast
Democrats are proposing open borders
lower wages and frankly lawless chaos we
are proposing an immigration plan that
puts the jobs wages and safety of
American workers first our proposal is
pro-american pro-immigrant
and pro worker it's just common sense
it will help all of our people including
millions of devoted immigrants to
achieve the American dream we are
grateful to be joined this afternoon by
a tremendous number of people from the
House the Senate and my cabinet and I
love you all but I won't introduce you
all because they'll be here all day long
but you're all here our planet Eve's two
critical goals first it stops illegal
immigration and fully secures the border
and second it establishes a new legal
immigration system that protects
American wages promotes American values
and attracts the best and brightest from
all around the world
the proposal begins with the most
complete and effective border security
package ever assembled by our country or
any other country for that matter so
important
this plan was not developed I'm sorry to
say by politicians we have a lot of
politicians but you respect the people
and you know the people that have
developed this plan it was designed with
significant input from our great
law-enforcement professionals to detail
what they need to make our border which
is 100 percent operationally secure 100
percent everyone agrees that the
physical infrastructure on the border
and the ports of entry is gravely
underfunded and woefully inadequate we
scan only a small fraction of the
vehicles Goods and all of the other
things coming across including people
and sadly the drugs pour across our
border we're gonna stop it investment in
technology will ensure we scan 100% of
everything coming through curbing the
flow of drugs and contraband while
speeding up legal trade and commerce
it's the most heavily traded monetarily
border anywhere in the world and it's
not even close to make certain that we
are constantly making the upgrades we
need our proposal creates a permanent
and self-sustaining border security
trust fund this will be financed by the
fees and revenues generated at the
border crossings itself importantly
we're already building the wall and we
should have close to 400 miles built by
the end of next year and probably even
more than that it's going up very
rapidly
and I want to thank the Army Corps of
Engineers are doing a fantastic job on
the wall and that's a wall that is
desperately needed as we close the gaps
in our physical framework we must also
close the gaps in our legal framework
critical to ending the border crisis is
removing all incentives for smuggling
women and children current law that's
right
women and children people have no idea
how bad it is unless you're there and
unless you are a member of law
enforcement they see it every day and
they can't believe what they see current
law and federal court rulings encourage
criminal organizations to smuggle
children across the border the tragic
result is that 65% of all border
crossers this year were either minors or
adults traveling with minors our plan
will change the law to stop the flood of
child smuggling and to humanely reunite
unaccompanied children with their
families back home and rapidly as soon
as possible
we must also restore the integrity of
our broken Asylum system our nation has
a proud history of affording protection
to those fleeting government
persecutions unfortunately legitimate
asylum seekers are being displaced by
those lodging frivolous claims these are
frivolous claims to gain admission into
our country asylum abuse also strains
our public school systems our hospitals
and local shelters using funds that we
should and that have to go to elderly
veterans at-risk youth Americans and
poverty and those in genuine need of
protection we're using the funds that
should be going to them and that
shouldn't happen and it's not going to
happen in a very short period of time
have to get this approved my plan
expedites relief for legitimate asylum
seekers by screening out the meritless
claims if you have a proper claim you
will quickly be admitted if you don't
you will promptly be returned home
crucially
our plan closes loopholes in federal law
to make clear that gang members and
criminals are inadmissible these are
some of the worst people anywhere in the
world ms-13 and others inadmissible not
coming in we're taking them out all the
time by the thousands a year but they
come in they are no longer admissible
and for criminals already here we will
ensure their swift deportation we will
keep our community safe Americans can
have complete and total confidence that
under this plan the borders will finally
be fully and totally secured and I know
a number of our Republican friends and
others Lindsay I see you sitting right
there and Steve you're working on a plan
an immediate plan a smaller plan but a
very immediate plan to stop it as of
this afternoon so as fast as you can get
something done this is the big beautiful
bold plan but we need something very
quickly and if you can get it done that
would be fantastic okay thank you
appreciate your working on a topic of
less discussion in national media but a
vital importance to our country is our
legal immigration system itself our plan
includes a sweeping modernization of our
dysfunctional legal immigration process
it is totally dysfunctional the system
will finally be fair transparent and
promote equality and opportunity for all
every year we admit 1.1 million
immigrants as permanent legal residents
these green card holders get lifetime
authorization to live and work here and
a five-year path to American citizenship
this is the most prized citizenship
anywhere in the world by far currently
66 percent of legal immigrants come here
on the basis of random chance they're
admitted solely because they have a
relative in the United States and it
doesn't really matter who that relative
is another 21 percent of immigrants are
issued either by random lottery or
because they are fortunate enough to be
selected for humanitarian relief
random selection is contrary to American
values and blocks out many qualified
potential immigrants from around the
world who have much to contribute while
countless and you wouldn't believe how
many countries like Canada create a
clear path for top talent America does
not under the senseless rules of the
current system we're not able to give
preference to a doctor a researcher a
student who graduated number one in his
class from the finest colleges in the
world anybody were not able to take care
of it we're not able to make those
incredible breakthroughs if somebody
graduates top of their class from the
best college sorry go back to your
country we want to keep them here
companies are moving offices to other
countries because our immigration rules
prevent them from retaining
highly-skilled and even if I might
totally brilliant people we discriminate
against genius
we discriminate against brilliance we
won't anymore once we get this past and
we hope to get it past as soon as
possible some of the most skilled
students at our world-class universities
are going back home because they have no
relatives to sponsor them here in the
United States and that's the only way we
want these exceptional students and
workers to stay and flourish and thrive
in America as a result of our broken
rules the annual green card flow is
mostly low wage and low skilled
newcomers compete for jobs against the
most vulnerable Americans and put
pressure on our social safety net and
generous welfare programs only 12% of
legal immigrants are selected based on
skill or based on merit in countries
like Canada Australia and New Zealand
and others that number is closer to
sixty and even seventy and seventy five
percent in some cases the biggest change
we make is to increase the proportion of
highly skilled immigration from 12% to
57% and we'd like to even see if we can
go higher
this will bring us in line with other
countries and make us globally
competitive at the same time we
prioritize the immediate family of new
Americans spouses and children the loved
ones you choose to build a life with we
pray artists and we have to do that they
go right to the front of the line right
to the front of the line where they
should be America's last major overhaul
of our legal admissions policy was 54
years ago think of that so a major
update and that's what this is merit
system and a heart system is long
overdue
the millions of legal immigrants who
have come to America over the past
half-century are now cherished members
of our national family going forward it
is their interest and in their interest
and their children's interest to adopt a
green card system that promotes a rising
standard of living for all of our
citizens three and four new jobs at the
end of last year went to Americans
previously out of the workforce our
economy is better probably than it ever
has been in the history of our country
and because of that great economy we're
able to do things that nobody ever
thought possible before and that's what
we're going to do for immigration
finally wages are rising but our current
immigration system works at
cross-purposes placing downward pressure
on wages for the working class which is
what we don't want to do last year we
also passed historic criminal justice
reform and we had tremendous backing
bipartisan from Democrats Republicans
conservatives liberals yes we could also
use the word progressives a new word
that's come about Americans with
criminal records are getting a second
chance at life in higher numbers than
ever before unfortunately the current
immigration rules allow foreign workers
to substitute for America's seeking
entry-level job so far and workers are
coming in and they're taking the jobs
that would normally go to American
workers America's immigration system
should bring in people who will expand
opportunity for striving low income
Americans not to compete with those low
income Americans
our proposal fulfills our sacred duty to
those living here today while ensuring
America remains a welcoming country to
immigrants joining us tomorrow and we
want immigrants coming in we cherish the
open door that we want to create for our
country but a big proportion of those
immigrants must come in through merit
and skill the White House plan makes no
change to the number of green cards
allocated each year but instead of
admitting people through random chance
we will establish simple the universal
criteria for admission to the United
States no matter where in the world
you're born no matter who your relatives
are if you want to become an American
citizen it will be clear exactly what
standard we ask you to achieve it will
be made crystal clear
this will increase the diversity of
immigration flows into our country we
will replace the existing green card
categories with a new visa the Build
America visa which is what we all want
to hear like Canada and so many other
modern countries we create an
easy-to-navigate points-based selection
system you will get more points for
being a younger worker meaning you will
contribute more to our social safety net
you will get more points for having a
valuable skill an offer of employment
and advanced education or a plan to
create jobs we lose people that want to
start companies and in many cases
they're forced to leave our country
go back usually to the country where
they came from and they'll start up
companies and some of those companies
are among the biggest and most
successful companies today in the world
they could have started them right here
in the United States where they wanted
to do it in the first place now they'll
have a chance
priority will also be given to higher
wage workers ensuring we never undercut
American labor to protect benefits for
American citizens immigrants must be
financially self-sufficient finally to
promote integration assimilation and
national unity future immigrants will be
required to learn English and to pass a
civics exam prior to admission through
these steps we will deliver an
immigration system that respects and
even strengthens our culture our
traditions and our values four months
ago I had the honor of participating in
a swearing-in ceremony for new Americans
right here in the Oval Office it was a
beautiful reminder that American
citizenship is the most precious gift
our nation has to offer when we swear in
new citizens we do more than give them a
permit we give them a history a heritage
a home and a future of limitless
possibilities and potential our nation
used to pride ourselves on this capacity
our unique ability to instill the spirit
of America into any human heart into any
human being many of the Democrats have
claimed to be for these concepts at
different times in their careers and in
many cases in very recent history and I
hope that they will end up joining me
and all of the people gathered together
today in putting politics aside putting
security and wages first and pursuing
these historic reforms
it's time and if for some reason
possibly political we can't get the
Democrats to approve this merit-based
high security plan then we will get it
approved immediately after the election
when we take back the house keep the
Senate and of course hold the presidency
thank you
thank you thank you very much but
wouldn't it be nice to do it sooner than
that but it's not a very long time is it
16 months one of the reasons we will win
is because of our strong fair and
pro-america immigration policy it's time
to restore our national unity and
reaffirm our national purpose it is time
to rebuild our country for all Americans
together we will create an immigration
system to make America safer and
stronger and greater than ever before
thank you god bless you all thank you
very much
[Applause]